vous céderez car vous ne tenez qu'à neuf
voix
vous céderez car de Français sur trois
souhaitent votre départ vous céderez car
passer en force contre le peuple les
syndicats le Parlement relève d'une
folie vous aiderez car le risque d'un
débordement de colère est déjà trop
grand vous céderez car la police seule
ne parviendra pas à faire régner l'ordre
vous céderez car un caprice du président
ne mérite pas de menacer la paix civile
du pays vous céderez car votre réforme
des retraites relève d'un choix
politique et qu'il est possible d'en
faire un tout autre vous céderez mais
vous aurez abîmé comme rarement la
parole politique
instrumentaliser la Constitution à des
fins autoritaires dévoyé comme jamais la
démocratie parlementaire confondue avec
une roulette russe quand ce n'est pas un
jeu de pile ou face
bafoué la démocratie sociale en traitant
les syndicats comme des figurants
attaquer le gros droit de grève et de
manifestation à coups de réquisition et
de répression les mots ont un sens
autoritarisme c'est le mot que vous
employez pour parler de notre
Constitution
illégitime
illégitime c'est le mot que vous
utilisez pour décrire le Parlement le
débat les institutions
assassin c'est l'insulte qui a hurlé
l'un de vos députés en attaquant le
ministre du Travail
dégoût fureur ce sont vos paroles hier
dans un registre haineux qui est
désormais votre habitude s'il vous plaît
censure populaire ce sont les mots de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelant au
soulèvement face au Parlement
madame la Présidente panneau hier soir
votre violence verbale a déborder dans
la rue mais alors là sans surprise
sans surprise vous n'avez plus de mots
pour condamner les violences
au contraire vous continuez sans roulage
votre attaque systématique des
institutions républicaines